SOME COMMENTARY FOR "THE FIVE,"
GREG, WHY DON'T WE START WITH
YOU AND YOUR OVERALL IMPRESSIONS
OF THE DAY.
>> Greg: WHAT AN ABSOLUTE
TREMENDOUS WASTE OF TIME FOR
EVERYONE WHO WATCHES THIS.
THIS IS NOT A HEARING.
IT IS A HUMAN RESOURCES MEETING,
OKAY.
ANYBODY WHO HAS BEEN ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE COIN, RIGHT?
EITHER YOU HAVE BEEN IN CHARGE
OF A PROJECT, OR AN INCOMING
BOSS.
UNDERSTANDS WHAT YOU ARE SEEING.
IT WORKS LIKE THIS, YOU ARE IN
CHARGE OF A DEPARTMENT, A NEW
BOSS COMES IN, HE NEEDS TO
ESTABLISH A NEW WAY, HIS STAMP,
YOUR PRIORITIES DON'T JIVE,
THERE IS A TUG-OF-WAR BETWEEN
SIDES, THE BOSS ALWAYS WINS.
HERE'S THE GREAT NEWS ABOUT THI
THIS, THE PRIORITIES THAT THE
PERSON LEAVING OFTEN REMAINS THE
CUSTODIAN IS GONE.
BUT THE STRUGGLE IS NECESSARY TO
PROVE THE VIABILITY OF THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE, RIGHT?
THEY SAY WE NEED THIS FOR THE
UKRAINE.
AND TRUMP IS LIKE, I DON'T KNOW.
IT COMES TOGETHER.
THIS IS NOT IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
OFFICE.
THE IRONY IS THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
FOR A LIVING ARE NOT HERE TO
WATCH THIS TO LAUGH AT THIS.
THE MEDIA THINKS IT IS
IMPORTANT, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NEVER BEEN AT A WORKPLACE
SITUATION.
THEY HAVE NEVER MANAGED
ANYTHING.
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN AN INCOMING
BOSS.
SO THEY ARE TRICKED INTO
THINKING THAT THIS IS SOMETHING